jazak Allah for your patience listening
now we have the presumably more
interesting session the question and
answer
session as you prepare your questions
for Dr Zakir and line up at the three
mics we have provided for you in the
ground one on my left in the front for
the gents one in the
rear on my left for the Gent and one in
the ladies section in the rare on my
right for the ladies
may I mention a short message of Dr
Zakir on occasion of this conference in
context of Peace TV he tells my dear
brothers and sisters in Islam and
Humanity assalamu alaykum may peace be
on you I welcome you to share in peace
TV's Global
mission and vision of creating a better
awareness and understanding of Islam as
a
just righteous and peaceful way of life
for the entire Humanity
share in removing misconceptions false
fear and hate of Islam and Muslims
globally this also is the focus of this
conference now as peace TV is telecast
to over 150 countries worldwide it
beckons your tawa spirit and support to
make it a household TV channel across
the
globe in all continents where it is
being broadcast presently except for
South
America not only in the Muslim homes but
also in millions of non-muslim homes
seeking reliable Islamic knowledge and
wisdom which many times is not available
in the mainstream
media now we start the question and
answer
session to generate more value from the
time available for our question and
answer session the following rules need
to be observed by the questioners your
questions must be on the topic is the
Quran God's
word your question should be brief and
to the point you may ask only one
question at a time for your second
question you need to queue again at the
back of the queue where you're
standing questions on the mic will be
given first
preference and if time permits
questions on slips would be given second
preference
non-muslims brothers and sisters will be
given first preference to put forward
the questions to Dr
Zakir this would be tackled and handled
by our volunteers at the question
mics then only would our Muslim brothers
and sisters be given questions
preference for asking questions to Dr
Zakir questions would be allowed only
from the mics these questions would be
allowed in a clockwise
rotation first for the ladies the second
for the gents third for the gents again
for the ladies gents and then for the
gents if you
have your questions kindly put it
forward now to Dr Zakir remember three
points on the topic brief and only one
at a time we'll allow the first question
for the ladies the second year the third
at the rare yes
sister okay I have one question in the
Surah Alam Ron verse
50 it says to follow the teachings of
Jesus why doesn't anyone do
this can you mention your name sister
please
chassid sister asked a question that the
the Quran says in Surah Imran chapter 3
verse number 50 that we have to follow
the teachings of Jesus Christ peace be
upon him and there are many verses which
say that we have to believe in Jesus
peace be upon Him Sister let me
clarify that Islam is the only
non-Christian Faith which makes it an
Article of Faith to believe in Jesus
Christ peace be upon him no muslim as a
Muslim if he does not believe in Jesus
Christ peace be upon
him we believe that he was one of the
mightiest messengers of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala we believe that he was the
Messiah transed Christ we believe that
he was born miraculously without any
male Intervention which many modern
Christians today do not believe we
believe that he gave life to the Dead
with God's
permission we believe that he healed
those born blind and lepers is God's
permission the Christian and the Muslim
sister we are going together but one may
ask where is The Parting of ways the
part of way is sister that many
Christians they say that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him he claimed Divinity he
said that he was almighty
God if you read the Bible sister there
is not a single unequivocal statement in
the complete Bible where Jesus Christ
peace be upon him himself says that I am
God or he says worship
me if any Christian can point out a
single unequivocal statement a single Un
ous statement in the complete Bible
where Jesus Christ peace be upon himself
says that I am God or where he says
worship me I am ready to accept
Christianity Today I not speaking on
behalf of my other Muslim
Brothers in fact if you read the Bible
it's mentioned in the Gospel of John
chapter number 14 verse number 28 Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said my father
is greater than I Gospel of John chapter
number 10 verse number 29 my father is
greater than All gospel of Matthew
chapter number 12 verse vers number 28 I
cast th Devil with the spirit of God
Gospel of Luke chapter number 11 verse
number 20 I cast th Devil with the
Finger of God Gospel of John chapter
number 5 verse number 30 I can of my own
self do nothing as I hear I judge and my
judgment is just for I seek not my will
but the will of almighty
God but the will of my father anyone who
says that I followed not my will but the
will of almighty God he's a Muslim Jesus
Christ peace be upon you as a Muslim he
never claimed Divinity and it's clearly
mentioned in the book of Acts chapter
number two verse number 22 e men of
Israel listen to this Jesus of Nazareth
a man approved of God amongst You by
wonders and miracles and signs which God
did by him and you are witness to it
Jesus of Nazareth a man approved of God
amongst You by wonders and miracles
which God did by and you witness to it
so we believe that Jesus Christ peace be
upon him he was one of the mightiest
messengers of God but he was not
God so here we differ as far as the
teachings are concerned your basic
question was that Quran says you have to
follow the teachings of Jesus Christ
peace be upon him when Jesus Christ
peace be upon Him came in this world he
was only sent for the Jews only for bani
Isel the Quran says
clearly in Surah saf chapter number 61
verse number six that Jesus Christ peace
be upon Him came as a messenger to the B
is it's mentioned Sur Al Imran chapter
number 3: 49 that Jesus chist peace be
upon him was sent only for the B Isel
it's mention in the gospel of
Matthew chapter number 10 verse number
five and six Jesus Christ peace be upon
him he says go not into the way of the
Gentiles who are the Gentiles non-jews
Hindus Muslims going not in the way of
the Gentiles entering not into the city
of the Samaritans but rather go to the
house of the lordship of Israel and a
similar message repeated in the gospel
of Matthew chapter number 15 verse
number 24 he says to his Apostles that I
have been sent not but to the lordship
of the House of Israel so Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was sent only for the
ban Israel and his message was supposed
to be followed only for a particular
time period that's what the Bible says
that's what the Quran says in spite of
this
sister if you read the Bible what Jesus
Christ peace be upon Him says if you
analyze it's mentioned in the gospel of
Luke that Jesus Christ peace be upon him
he was circumcised on the eighth
day we Muslim Mas Allah we are
circumcised majority of the Christians
aren't circumcised so if you say that
following the teachings of Jesus Christ
peace be upon him makes you a Christian
then I like to say that I'm more
Christian than the Christian themselves
it is mentioned in the
Bible in the book of Ephesians chapter
number 5 5 verse number 18 that be not
drunk It's mentioned the Book of
Proverbs Chapter number 20 verse number
one that wine is a mocker we Muslims we
don't drink alcohol Quran says in Surah
ma chapter number 5 vers number 90
alcohol is Haram we don't touch it we
don't touch it as a whole the Muslims
are the biggest community of te
tolers so according to the Bible you
should not have alcohol it's mentioned
in the Bible that you should not have
poke in s places it's mentioned in the
Book of Leviticus chapter number 11
verse number 7 and 8 it's mentioned the
book of Deuteronomy chapter number 14
verse number 8 in the book of Isaiah
chapter number 65 verse number 2 to5 no
less than five places that you should
not have
poke we Muslims we don't have poke but
majority of the Christians they have
poke so if Christian means a person who
follows the teachings of Jesus Christ
peace be upon him we Muslims are more
Christian than the Christians themselves
I can go on and on when Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was asked that which
is the first of The Commandments he
mentioned in the gospel of
Mark chapter number 12 verse number 29
he
said it's a Hebrew quotation which means
your Israel the Lord our God is one Lord
we Muslims mashallah we believe in none
but one God majority of the Christian
they Believe In
trity Father Son and Holy Ghost
so if you say
Christian means the person who follows
the teachings of Jesus Christ peace be
upon him we Muslims are more Christian
than the Christian themselves and you
can refer to my video cassette
similarities between Islam and
Christianity which will give you more
details that we are following more of
the Bibles the teachings of Jesus Christ
peace be upon him than the Christian
themselves hope that answers the
question
sister may I request our questioners to
kindly State their names and profession
so that we get a clear context with what
background they're asking their question
and Zakir can inshallah give you a more
appropriate
response and uh we would request our
volunteers to kindly see that very
courteously the non-muslim brothers and
sisters are given the first preference
may I put this two also in context the
objective is the brothers this is an
open question answer session and you can
feel free to ask any questions on the
topic of the
day and you are totally free to
criticize Islam attack Islam if Dr Zakir
is speaking anything which is wrong or
not speaking appropriate to the context
of peace or what the message of Islam
States and it is against the basic
Humanity feel free to ask him you are
under a full protection and we
appreciate a person who would criticize
us openly in a context like this than a
person who would be against and feel bad
in the heart and not come out in the
open about what we feel we want you to
come out in the open ask questions
criticize attack Dr zaker this is your
opportunity please don't miss it now
this is your opportunity for the next
one hour feel free to ask question yes
brother asalam Alum my name is Ludovic
Bon I am French
non-muslim and uh I am traveling eight
months in India I uh am 18 years old I
compell my 12 in June and so uh inshah
if you agree I will meet you in private
but now uh I just would like to ask you
um about the Jews uh maybe if I am not
wrong you said that uh it is written in
the Quran that Jews and pans are
the uh strength uh strong enemies uh of
Believers Muslim Believers Muslim and uh
I would like to know how this verse can
fize peace in uh in uh
humankind uh when we see the troubles
between Palestine and
Israel uh how some Muslim and some Jews
can
uh cannot be uh cannot misunderstand
this verse because maybe it can uh
provoke uh it can provoke some uh Mis
misinterpretation or if it's r that uh
Jews and Muslim have to be
enemies brother as a good question that
he said I said in my speech and Accord
the of the Quran of Sur MAA 5: 82 which
says that strongest in enmity to the
Muslims would be the Jews and the pagans
and the closest In Love would be the
Christians so he say won't it create
enemity when they say that the Jews and
the Muslims should fight the Quran
doesn't say Jews and the Muslim should
fight the Quran says strongest
enmity to the Muslims to the Believers
will be Jews it does not say that
Muslims should fight with the Jews it
doesn't say that but it says that the
Jews by Nature as a
whole they'll be against Muslims and I
told in my lecture there are many Jews
who accepted Islam there are many Jews
are good to Muslims but as a whole as a
whole if you take Jews as a whole and
the Christians as a whole the Christians
are closer than the Jews as a whole this
is a
fact for example the Quran says that the
Jews are intelligent also that's a fact
if they IG intelligent that doesn't mean
that it hides the fact and the Quran
also says that they will be as a whole a
stous enemy so this is one of the
falsification test that today if you
want to prove the Quran wrong if the
Jews the Jews get together all of them
and they decide that let's prove the
Quran wrong at least for 3 4 years we
will be better than the Christians let's
stop the war of Palestine you know the
Palestinians the Jews were kicked out by
Hitler Hitler and uned 6 million Jews he
kicks them out of
Germany the Arabs the Palestinians they
do Alan veran come with open
arms after a few years they kicked out
of the
home imagine someone gives a traveler is
home to live and the traveler kicks him
out of his home and he's shouting that
he has taken my house and you're calling
them
terrorists so what they have to do is
let's get together and solve this
problem whatever the problem is
today America is controlled by the Jews
whether it be the banks whether it be
the money whether it be the power
according to the American survey no one
can become a president of USA without
walking the Star of
David though the Jews are a minority
less than 5% in America but they're
controlling the economy they're
controlling
America fine so they're controlling
America let all of the let solve the
problem of Palestine let solve the
American problem not forever
few
years four five years only and the
problem is Sol so we aren't telling that
the Muslim should fight with the Jews in
fact the Quran says even if your enemy
want peace several places even if they
come to fight you it's mentioned sural
in the battle if they want peace give it
to them so Quran is always for
peace Quran is always encouraging them
but if a person does not want peace to
Prevail what can we do Islam is a
religion of peace
it wants peace but even mention
facts that means we have to be careful
of the Jews not that we have to fight
them unless they come and fight with you
that's a different thing imagine what's
happening in Palestine what's happening
other parts of the world so brother for
peace to Prevail you have to follow the
guidance of the Quran and live
harmoniously rather than be enemies so
Quran doesn't say that Jews should be
enemies but they will be same hope that
answer the question
can we have the next question from the
brother in the
r i Am Mr
Chan uh retired teacher before question
I would like to Salam all of
youum my question
is the Quran is word of God as you
propounded in uh detail several but I
doubt that Quran is not only the word of
God but it is mixture of God's and
Prophets word how because in several
verses you say you mention that uh I
have not written as Prophet mentioning
that I have not written it is not my
word wherever he has clarified that it
is not my work so what about these words
these are not his words
please brother asked a very good
question and that logic I use when I
speak to the Christians about the Bible
the brother said that undoubtedly you
proved it the word of God but besides
being the word of God there's words of
prophet because it's mentioned in the
Quran I did not write
it brother no verse of the Quran says I
did not write it you point out the verse
and I'll accept that the Quran is not
the word of God
[Applause]
what does the Quran say they say that
the prophet wrote it and I quoted maybe
you misheard me what I said that Surah s
chapter number 32 verse number 1 2 3
they say that the prophet forged it tell
them n it is the truth from almighty God
it is almighty God talking if the
prophet wrote it then I agree with you
this is what is mentioned in the Bible
in the Bible it says says that Moses
peace be upon him he
says that I
died on so and so neither Moses wrote
neither God wrote it so Moses wrote the
book how can he say that I
died so that's what you find in the
Bible Jesus Christ peace be upon Him
speaking so what do we say as far as the
Quran is concerned never will you find
any direct speech of the Prophet if it
is it is quoted by almighty God
in inverted Commerce almighty God may
say that the prophet replied but never
does the Quran say I did not write
it in fact the Quran says it is from
almighty God and I quoted several verses
if you want me to repeat I can repeat
again Surah chapter number 6 verse
number 19 suram chapter number 6 verse
number 93 Surah Yu chapter number 12
verse number 1 and 2 and Surah chter
number 20 verse number3 in Sur s 32 vers
number 1 to3 in Sur y CH number 3 vers
number 1 to3 in CH number 39 vers number
one in ch 40 vers number two in surash
ch 45 vers number two several places the
Quran says this book is a revelation
from almighty God direct
speech hope to answer the
question yes
sister hi my name is Sarah I'm uh
independent student I graduated in
America I'm here studying independently
um as you have stated Jesus never does
claim Divinity in the Bible in
Revelation chapter 1 I can't read the
whole chapter because it would take a
very long time but Jesus is speaking and
he says do not be afraid I am the first
and the last I am the living one I was
dead and behold I am alive forever and
ever I hold the keys of death and Hades
he also says I am the Alpha and the
Omega who is and who was and who is to
come the almighty these are also names
of God written in the Old and New
Testament and I don't see how that does
not show that Jesus is not genetically
the Son of God but spiritually the Son
of
God the last question she quoted
Revelation chapter number one she didn't
give the verses she's talking about the
first 20 verses and I'm Alpha and Omega
is verse number 11 Revelation chapter
number one verse number 11 where Jesus
Christ peace be upon Him says that I'm
Alpha and
Omega so she says just because Jesus
Christ peace be upon Him says I'm Alpha
and Omega I'm first and the last
according to you he's claiming Divinity
Mark me I had said there is not a single
unequivocal statement not a single
ambigous statement in the complete Bible
where Jesus Christ peace be upon himself
says that I am God or where he says
worship me he didn't say now you are
saying that because Jesus said I'm Alpha
and Omega therefore he's almighty God
what do you mean Alpha and Omega I'm the
first and the last in what do you mean
Jesus Christ was first in this world no
he was born in a stable before him was
his mother there were many prophets that
came before him so surely he's not the
first neither is he the last in the
Bible it says Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he'll be coming it's mentioned
in the Gospel of John chapter number 16
verse number 12- 14 I have many to say
unto you but he cannot bear them now for
he when the spirit of truth shall come
he shall guide you un all truth he shall
not speak of himself all that he he
shall he speak he shall glorify me he
shall show you things to come talking
about prophet Muhammad's peace be upon
him so what does this word alpha and
omega mean it does not mean that he
first and the last actually
literally because there were many people
who came before him and the many people
who came after him what does it mean
that in the law of God whatever the
messenger says the law of God is first
and last at the time of Moses Moses was
alpha and omega as far as the law of God
was concerned whatever he taught had to
be followed at the time of Jesus Jesus
Christ peace be upon him his teachings
were Alpha and Omega it had to be
followed at the time of prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him his teachings are
alpha and omega it is a the first and
the
last it does not mean that he claimed
Divinity so therefore I said any
unambiguous statement if you literally
mean he first and last if you read the
Bible the Bible disagrees there were
many people who came before Jesus Christ
peace be upon him he was born in the
womb of the mother and various people
came after him also so surely sister
therefore I said unambiguous unequivocal
statement hope the answer the
question yes brother
my name is Aran arra Kumar Naran Singh K
from
DHI I speak no continue English to
English I'm very very sorry
part
the brothers asked two questions the
first question is can there be change in
the law and the teachings of almighty
God can there be changes and question
two is that can a person be
reborn can he be reborn and he quoted a
verse of the Gita which are come to it
later on as far as the first question is
concerned can the laws of God keep on
changing if the law of God is time bound
if it's meant for only a particular
group of people and for a particular
time period it will keep on
changing for example as I mentioned my
talk Tor zabur injil all of them were
revelation of God but they were meant
for a particular group of people and for
particular time
period but once the last and final
revelation of God has been revealed
nothing new can be
added nothing can be
subtracted Quran is the last and final
revelation of almighty God no other
Revelation going to come Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him is the last
and final messenger there is no other
Messenger to come Allah says in 30 verse
number
40 that Muhammad peace be upon Him is
not the father of any of you men but he
is the messenger of Allah and is the
Seal of the prophets and Allah is all
knowing full of wisdom after Prophet
Muhammad if anyone says that that he is
a messenger of God he gets Revelation
then he requires a
psychiatrist Prophet Muhammad is the
last and final messenger after Quran no
other Revelation going to come and Quran
clearly mentioned in Sur ma 5 verse
number three on this day have I
completed my religion for you and I've
chosen for you Islam and complete my
favor on you once the religion is
completed nothing new can be added
nothing can be subtracted so as far your
question yes the old
Revelations they can can be changes but
the basic message from the first
revelation till the last abouted about
Oneness of God is the same so all the
revelations that came before the Quran
they have not maintained the pure form
they have been changed by human beings
and because it was not meant for
eternity almighty God didn't feel it fit
to be preserved but as far as the Quran
is concerned Allah says in Surah chapter
number 15 verse number 9 we have
revealed the Quran and we shall guard it
from corrupt
this Quran even if all the human beings
try and change the Quran they cannot do
it all the human being and Jin they get
together they can't change the Quran so
as far as the previous Revelation yes
there can be a change but the final
Revelation no it cannot be changed it is
the
ultimate now coming to a second
question second question
m
the asked another new question so I told
him first I reply to the old question
then I come to the new question his
previous question was that do you
believe in reincarnation in a second
life as far as reincarnation is
concerned what you quoted is bhagwat
Gita but the highest scripture in
Hinduism is V vas are number
one they are the
shis then later on comes the smes
Mahabharat part of Mahabharat is bhagat
Gita though bhagat Gita is more widely
read Than The Vedas but authenticity in
grade Veda is high the V speaks about
punjan punjan mean next life and if you
read the Quran the Quran too speaks
about next life Quran says you'll come
in this world you'll die again you'll be
resurrected punar means next Janam means
life pun Janam nowhere does the Veda
speaks about death Life Death Life Death
Life Death life
nowhere
nowhere neither does the bhagat Gita
speak about that what you quoted to me
is a verse of bhagwad Gita chapter
number four verse number
22 I'm giving you the
reference where it's mentioned in
bhagwat Gita according to the Hindus
it's a word of almighty God and it says
that as the human beings keep on
changing the clothes they throw away the
old clothes and put on new clothes same
way the soul will take a new body we'll
throw away the old body new body I have
got no problem in this world you have
this body when you die you rejected new
body no problem it is matching with the
Quran matching with the
V but this philosophy what you're
talking about reincarnation in Sanskrit
it is called as
Samara the theory of reincarnation the
theory of life and death called as
rebirth correct now this theory was
propounded by the scholars of Hinduism
it's nowhere mentioned in the vas why
because they could not jus ify some
people are born deaf some people born
rich some people born in a poor family
some people are born healthy some people
conal heart disease how can God be
unjust so they couldn't justify so they
came with the philosophy of death Life
Death life Karma and Dharma karma is the
deed action Dharma is the law so what
justification how can God be unjust how
can a person be born with a heart
disease ah last life he did some sin
this was a philosophy assumption by the
scholars of Hinduism not by
V so then they came with this philosophy
and they say that if you do good deeds
in your next life you'll be born of a
higher
degree and the universal bre of Hinduism
is all living creatures
are so maybe you're born sometime as a
cockro sometime as a rat sometime as a
cat sometime as a dog sometime as human
being human being is the highest level
so if you do good deeds you're born
higher if you do bad Deeds you're born
lower F and you're born as a human being
seven times how many times seven the
philosophy of the Hindu Scholars called
as samsara now I'm asking a question
brother in this world sin is increasing
or
decreasing
sin mashah very good sin is increasing
population of human
being bir mashallah so sin is also
increasing and human beings are
increasing if sin is increasing human
being should
increase so what we realize logically
it's not correct therefore I believe in
Punam Punam is next life which Quran
speaks about next life but only one you
come in this world only one
now coming to your third question about
Brahma
Vishnu
mahesa same same two names Mah and sha
same but more popular sha right the
Creator the Destroyer the sustainer
Brahma Vishnu
Shiva and you ask me that does God have
these three forms no God doesn't have
three forms does he have any people yes
he has many angels see alone God is
sufficient he does not require anyone's
help but if he wants he can do it
through an angel if he wants if he
doesn't want no problem he just wills
and it
is be and it is as far as the Hindus
what they believe they believe in
somewhat similar Trinity what the
Christians believe even the Hindus
believe that almighty God one God is God
to create Brahma one God is God to
destroy Shiva one God is God to sustain
Vishnu so to separate God for creation
separate God for sustaining separate God
for
destroying the Quran
says in Surah Ambia CH 21 verse number
22 if there were Gods more than one God
surely they would have fought among
themselves and Quran says in Surah
chapter number 23 verse number 91 that
if there were many gods they would have
piled upon one another and that's what
we find in Hindu mythology one God
fighting with other God one God the
other God third God helping the second
God how can God fight so best is only
one God super power is only one and that
is what the V says if you ask a common
Hindu how many gods does he believe in
some will say three some will say 100
some will say thousand some will say 33
cres 330 million but if you ask a
learned Hindu that how many gods should
a Hindu believe in he will tell you
Hindu should believe only in one
God but the common Hindu he believed in
a philosophy known as
pantheism what he says that everything
is God the tree is God the sun is God
the Moon is God the human being is God
and the snake is God what we Muslims
say everything is gods g o with an
apostrophe everything belongs to God the
tree belongs to God the sun belongs to
God the moon belongs to God the human
being belongs to God as well as this
thing belongs to God so the major
difference between the Hindus and the
Muslims is the Hindus say everything is
God we Muslims say everything is gods g
o d with an apostrophes the major
difference is
apostrophe if we can solve this
difference of apostrophes the Hindus and
the Muslims we'll be
United how do we do
it Allah says in the Quran in Surah Al
Imran chapter number 3 verse number
64 come to come in terms as between us
and you which is the first term
that we worship none but
Allah that we associate or partners with
him that we erect not among ourselves
Lords and PR other than Allah if then
they turn
back say we bear witness that we are
Muslims bowing to Allah subhana tala the
best way to analyze any religion is not
to try and understand what the followers
are doing but you have to analyze the
scriptures now if we analyze Hindu
scriptures if we read the upanishads
which V upanishad the highest it's
mentioned chapter number six section
number two verse number
one God is only one without a second it
a Sanskrit
quotation God is only one without a
second it's mentioned
inan chapter number six verse number
n of him there is no Lord he has got no
parents all Mighty God has got no
Superior he has got no mother he has got
no father it's mentioned in thean
chapter number four verse number
19 ATI of that God there is no pratima
pratima means image pratima means
photograph Idol sculpture painting
almighty God has got no photograph has
got no sculptures has got no statue has
got no painting he has got no
images and amongst the Hindu scriptures
the most sacred are the vi it's
mentioned chapter number 32 verse number
three of that almighty God there is no
pratima there is no images there is no
photograph there is no sculpture there's
no statue it's mentioned J chapter
number 40 verse number 8 almighty God is
pure it's mentioned J 40 verse number
n they entering Darkness those who
worship theti are the natural things
like fire water air Etc and the verse
continues they are entering more in
darkness those who worship the STI STI
are the created things like table chair
Idol Etc who says that yaj chapter
number 40 verse number n and the Brahma
of Hinduism
is there is only one God not a second
one not at all not at all not in the
least
B uh we' like our audience to give this
young boy a good hand because I think
when We Are Young we are more innocent
we are more righteous we are more
truthful he's an example of it putting a
very genuine question he had a genuine
question he believed in a genuine
approach alhamdulillah uh may we have
the next question from the brother in
the back hello uh Mr jair this is Aurora
VI being a Hindu over here I'm not over
here to put any
controversy but I have a question aham
Brahma aham Vishnu aham Mahesh that was
called by someone of my very good friend
eventually he was telling us about Quran
and Bible but what my question is I have
got just four question to ask to you
number one most important question first
if there is time we will definitely
permit you another question no issues no
issues because if everyone asks two
three questions if I as an coordinator
allow I think we are not being fair to
the other questioners fine thank I got
your point just one question as though
Mr ja you were talking about J's version
and everything I just have a put one
question if you are making a comparison
between the Quran and Bible why not a
comparison between the vas the Quran and
the Bible they are wor stle in each
every manner one it eventually is
cooperated with each other God the
almight is one rather it called be as
Allah it's called by bhagan or Jesus why
not make it sure all of the people
should say why not only
one brother asked a very good question
very important question very practical
question when are making comparison
between Quran and the Bible why not make
comparison between Quran Bible Veda Etc
and he said that why don't you follow
all and that is what I tell the people
that's for the Quran
says come to come in terms as you
brother what I tell every human being
any whether it be a Hindu Christian
Muslim Jew sik Pary no problem I tell
them a simple thing which everyone will
agree at least agree that one scripture
is the word of God no one would mind
doing that the Hindu would say okay fine
V is the word of God Christian would say
Bible is the word of God Muslim would
say Quran is the word of God
the sick he'll say my gr is the word of
God the Pary he will say that my AA is
the word of God no problem now put all
these scriptures together what is common
let us agree to follow that what is not
common we can discuss that tomorrow
correct I only ask them one thing what
is common in all the scriptures let us
agree to follow because sorry to
interrupt you sir sorry to interrupt you
brother please let me complete the
answer and after please please please
please after I finish after I finish the
answer what you want you can say maybe
what you want to ask I will give in the
answer correct I going stepwise right
sir the mathematical if you want to
solve a problem if I direct give you the
answer you w understand I have to go
stepwise 1 2 3 4 fine
exactly so my only request is what is
common in all the scriptures let us
follow what is not common we'll discuss
later
on fine now common in all the scripture
is
that God is
one so let us believe God is One V says
that God is one didn't I say
that God is the only one without a
second Bible says that Gospel of Mark
chapter number 12 verse number 29 book
of Deuteronomy chapter number 6 verse
number
four the Lord our God is one the Jews
say that the Christians say that Quran
says say there's God one and only so
where does this trity come in between
where does this Brahma Vishnu and Shiva
come in between
where I didn't believe in that brother
let me complete there is no Brahma
mentioned in the Quran there is no Shiva
mentioned in the
Quran there is no Jesus mentioned in the
Quran that he's God it's mentioned the
Quran is a messenger of God the Bible
also doesn't say that Jesus is God it is
the false reading of the Christians so
how come you are saying that it doesn't
matter whether Allah Jesus it
matters the Quran says
in is number 17 verse
110 say call upon Him by Allah or by
rman by whichever name you call upon him
to him belongs the most beautiful names
it should be a beautiful name it should
not conj up a mental picture it should
be a true name you can't give a false
name to God you can't insult God you
can't belittle God some people tell me
what different does it make you call
Pani you call water you call Tani no
problem if you call Pani you say in
Hindi Tani you say in Tamil MOA or my
you say in
Arabic jel you say in Hindi no problem
you can call by any name but then one
morning my friend comes and tells me
every morning I have
water but after I have water the doctor
told me I have a lot of water but I
start vomiting I said why no the water
is yellowish the doctor told him to have
water he has every morning one glass of
water the water is yellowish
yellowish then I realize what is talking
is not water it is
urine you can't call urine as water the
definition of water you can call Tani
you can call water you can say Rahman
you can say Rahim you can say Karim you
can say R but you can't call God as man
you can't call God as
insan therefore you can't call water as
urine
and the Touchstone for theology is
surlas chapter number 112 verse number 1
to 4 what I mention surlas so what I'm
going to tell that what is different
keep it aside nowhere does the Quran
says that Jesus is God nowhere does the
Quran says mahish is God so keep mahes
out yes if you say
Brahma Brahma is a Sanskrit word which
is known as a Creator God so if you say
Creator I've got no problem if you say
God is a Creator I've got no problem
because Quran says that God is khik
Creator but then you say this creator
has got four heads he has got four hands
then you're giving an image to God
you're going against
V of that God there is no
image I do believe so call him Creator
but you say that Creator is a man then
he's not
God I do have a apolog the Creator so
same way brother if you see my video
cassette similarities between Islam and
Hinduism inshallah most of your carries
will be answered hope to answer the
question I do apologize what I was
specifically want to say to you Mr zir I
do not want to get into controversy over
here um my thing is this Mr jair was
telling appropriately right what exactly
was over here the people is wanting what
I wanted to know basically
exactly what he the speeches he is
providing to us we are over to listen
him exactly the
Rena the Rena the creator of the world
rather it should be counted as
Allah bhagan or the Jesus should not be
created in it has to be materialized
with
differentiations thank
you brother if you had heard heard my
answer you call him Allah I've got no
problem you call him bhagwan as long as
what is the meaning of bhagan according
to rajnish bhagan means something else I
don't know whether you know according to
rajnish what definition rashish gave
then I cannot believe God is bhagan what
we have to realize we have to believe in
the
concept of the almighty the Creator the
maker if you know that concept and the
word should be chosen correct it should
not be a wrong word and what word is
common between the scriptures we have
got no objection but Jesus as you again
mentioned is not common in the Bible and
the Quran Quran says Jesus is a prophet
of God and even the Bible says the
prophet of God but the Christian they
misunderstand that Jesus claimed
Divinity so if the Christians they
misunderstand the Bible why should I
agree with the misunder understanding I
have to clarify that I have not come
here to create a controversy I've come
here to come to Common terms
come to come in terms ask us and you